you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now while we
are filling up the screen with almost
nothing but Blue Sky you got the Las
Vegas Skyline and the flag this camera
on top of the Molasky family of
companies Bank of America around the
rainbow curve at times we're getting
some gusts to maybe 15 to 20 miles an
hour officially 54 degrees at Reed
International just about everybody in
the low to the mid 50s all over the
valley got 56 at the Air Force Base and
again the breezes out of the north kind
of coming and going of course it's
cooler as you might expect up at Kyle
Kane and Mount Charleston checking in at
39. Reno also at 39 so's Tonopah and
still getting down to the teens at night
up in Ely which you would expect at this
time of year warm spot of course Death
Valley 66 over the hump in front
53-61 down in Laughlin and good
afternoon to Cedar City you guys are
near the freezing Mark so after a high
of 60 yesterday we're only going for 55
today so a little bit of cooler air is
settling in on top of us that will
slowly change with a little bit of a
warming Trend before more changes into
the weekend low this morning at 43 as
close to normal as you can get meantime
yeah there is a front coming into the
Pacific Northwest bringing rain and snow
mix up there to the Pacific Northwest
and some big time temperature changes in
the Rockies that is snow leaving
Colorado heading into parts of Nebraska
but we wanted to draw your attention to
this red rectangle with the cold air
from the Upper Midwest mixing with the
warmer moist air from the Gulf there's
the potential for tornadoes not only
here but we expect there will be more
tornado watches across the Deep South as
this thing marches across we'll keep you
posted so here are the right now
temperatures 25 for Minneapolis 20 in
Denver but you contrast that with 60 in
Nashville 78 in New Orleans so there is
a clash Zone here Ted florendo will keep
you posted this afternoon here's your
most accurate eight day forecast we'll
be up to 58 with a couple of breezes
tomorrow windy on Thursday with a high
of 60 and then more clouds rolled in
from the Pacific Northwest slight
chances for rain Friday and Saturday
we're not talking about major
accumulation and then another round of
wind into next week brings those high
temperatures back down so we'll keep an
eye on all the weather for you
throughout the day John all right Nate
thank you sir